flames burn for a second day at the
balaswa landfill adding to the hazardous
air quality in the capital
the plumes of smoke hard for anyone to
avoid especially waste workers
there's a fire every year it's not new
there is a risk to life and livelihood
many slum dwellings caught fire people
left but what do we do
picking through rubbish to earn a living
their only option is to carry on and
risk the dangerous smoke as firefighters
continue to battle the blaze
we are very scared we inhale these gases
which cause diseases i feel pain while
breathing and there are many others like
this
indians are suffering a heat wave which
is adding to the risk of fires march was
the hottest month in more than a century
prime minister narendra modi warned
state governments that temperatures are
rising much earlier than normal leading
to wildfires and fires in buildings such
as hospitals he's urging the urgent
implementation of safety checks
the landfill was supposed to close years
ago the decaying waste produces methane
gas that feeds the fire
instead of shutting the waste dump the
city adds 2 000 tons of new waste every
day
andrew chappelle al jazeera
time now for